♪
>> Sean: MORE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
WE ARE FOLLOWING MULTIPLE
BREAKING STORIES INCLUDING A
BOMBSHELL REPORT FROM THE
HILL REVEALING THAT THE FBI
IS OPENING A NEW
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AND ALSO
BREAKING THE DAILY BEAST
REPORTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS TAKEN A FRESH
SCANDAL.
AND ACCORDING TO THE REPORT
DOJ OFFICIALS NOW ARE
INFORMATION WAS, IN FACT,
SENT OVER CLINTON'S SERVER
WHO PUT THAT INFORMATION IN
TO AN UNCLASSIFIED
ENVIRONMENT AND HOW.
THEY ARE ALSO REPORTING THEY
WANT TO KNOW WHICH
INVESTIGATORS KNEW ABOUT
THESE MATTERS AND WHEN DID
THEY KNOW IT?
AND IN LIGHT OF TODAY'S
REPORT, FORMER SENIOR
ADVISOR TO CLINTON, PHILIPPE
REINES WROTE ON TWITTER,
QUOTE:  THIS IS DEFINITELY A
POLITICAL PERSECUTION.
REALLY?
HERE WITH REACTION FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTORS TOMI LAHREN AND
JESSICA TARLOV.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO BOTH OF
YOU.
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> Sean: HERE IT IS, YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT JAMES COMEY
MONTHS BEFORE EVEN
INVESTIGATING THE EMAIL
SPECIAL CATEGORY FOR
HILLARY.
IT WASN'T DONE BY THE FIELD
OFFICES OF THE FBI.
NOW THAT THEY'RE OPENING
INVESTIGATION INTO BOTH OF,
THIS CAN YOU JUST ADMIT YOU
CAN'T WRITE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION?
>> NO, I CAN'T ADMIT THAT.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T ADMIT
THAT?
>> ACCORDING TO SEVERAL.
INVESTIGATION LATER.
>> SEVERAL SAID IT WAS
NORMAL PRACTICE DRAFTING
>> Sean: YOU COMPLETELY TAKE
MYER ARGUMENT AND DISMISS
IT?
>> IT'S NOT WHAT I THINK
THIS EITHER.
SOME.
>> THAT GUY WAS A KASICH
SUPPORTER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THAT'S WHO HE WANTED.
>> Sean: HE IS ON TEXTS WITH
HIS GIRLFRIEND SAYING LA LA
LA LA.
>> HE WAS ALSO ON TEXT WITH
GIRLFRIEND SAYING I LIKE
JOHN KASICH.
>> Sean: TOMI, YOUR
THOUGHTS.
>> WHEN WILL WE HEAR FROM
HILLARY.
SHE LIKES TO TALK USUALLY IN
ANTI-TRUMP FASHION.
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS COMING
OUT ABOUT HILLARY.
ANYTHING COME OUT ABOUT
HILLARY.
THESE ARE REINVESTIGATIONS
SETTLED.
JEFF SESSIONS IS SCARED OF
DONALD TRUMP.
HE GOES ON TWITTER AND HE
SAYS LOCK HER UP AGAIN.
HE SAYS MY DOJ IS SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING.
THIS THIS IS PRESSURE NOT
BECAUSE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT?
HOLD ON, DO YOU THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE
INVESTIGATE THIS?
DO YOU THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO BE TAKEN?
>> 100 PERCENT.
THAT'S WHY WE DID IT
ALREADY.
>> Sean: EXCUSE ME, ALL ALREADY.
EMAIL HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
>> PRIVATE EMAIL?
PRIVATE SERVENER SOMEONE'S
3W5EU6789 WHEN THE SECRETARY
OF STATE JESSICA?
>> Sean: WE KNOW IN THE
CLINTON CASE TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAM INFORMATION IT WAS
ALL THERE.
AND THAT FOREIGN AGENT IT
WAS IN THE COMEY DRAFT HAD
LIKELY GOTTEN IT.
>> HAD LIKELY GOTTEN IT.
NOT CONFIRMED.
>> Sean: SHE PUT IT IN A MOM
AND POP SHOP BATHROOM
CLOSET.
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE BATHROOM.
>> THAT WAS A NEW LITTLE NEW
YEAR'S HUMOR.
YOU DON'T GET MY JOKES THIS
YEAR.
WAS A MISTAKE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM THIS?
>> Sean: NO.
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION DESTROYING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IS A
FELONY.
HAMMERS AND DELETE IT THAT'S
CALLED OBSTRUCTION.
>> JAMES COMEY JUST DID THIS
>> EXACTLY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE LETTER
THAT CAME OUT RIGHT BEFORE
THE ELECTIONS THAT WE ALL
AGREED I KNOW JUDGE PIERRE
WAS CERTAINLY SAYING THAT.
>> Sean: HE HAD NO CHOICE
TOMI AT THAT POINT THERE WAS
NO CHOICE.
>> TO BRING UP SOMETHING
THAT WAS COMPLETELY
IRRELEVANT IN THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> DESPITE ALL OF THIS,
DESPITE ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WANTED TO SEE HILLARY WIN,
I'M EXCITED BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE TOO
SMART FOR IT.
SO I PUT THAT A WIN IN OUR
COLUMN.
YES, WE ARE STILL GOING TO
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S A
MATTER OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
I WANT TO SEE HILLARY COME
OUT AND FESS UP.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE HER
COME OUT ANYMORE.
EVERY WEEK YOU SAY YOU ARE
DONE SEEING HER.
I JARED KUSHNER AND OTHER
OFFICIALS USING PRIVATE
EMAIL.
>> Sean: DON'T FALL INTO HER
DIVERSION.
>> Sean: HERE IS WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW.
AMERICA DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
URANIUM.
IT'S THE FOINGSAL MATERIAL
FOR NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
NOW, WHY WOULD WE EVER.
WHY WOULD HILLARY, ERIC
HOLDER, WHY WOULD KNOWING
ROBERT MUELLER KNEW THAT
PUTIN WANTED TO GET A FOOT
HOLD IN THE URANIUM INDUSTRY
IN AMERICA.
AND HE HAD HIS THUGS IN THIS
COUNTRY BRIBING E EXTORTING
MONEY LAUNDERING,
RACKETEERING THE WHOLE BIT
AND KICK BACKS.
WHY WOULD AMERICA -- WHY
WOULD ANYBODY EVER SIGN OFF
ON GIVING A FOREIGN ENTITY
CONTROL OF YOORM WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH URANIUM.
>> WE DIDN'T TRANSFER
URANIUM OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: EXKEY ME, WRONG.
IT WENT TO EUROPE AND WE
BELIEVE IT WENT TO ASIA.
>> WE BELIEVE IT WENT THERE.
>> Sean: WE KNOW IT WENT TO
CANADA.
>> IT WENT TO ALLIES BECAUSE
I BELIEVE EUROPE AND CANADA
ARE OUR ALLIES.
YOU ARE SAYING IT WENT INTO
PUTIN'S POCKET.
THAT'S ANOTHER THING.
>> WE ARE RESOURCE SCARCE?
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T SIGN
OFF ON THAT.
>> Sean: SHE DID SIGN OFF ON
IT THAT'S A LIE.
>> AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
SHE DID NOT.
>> Sean: PASS THE BUCK.
>> WE KNOW IT THERE ARE SO
MANY SMOKING ELEMENTS HERE
KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THIS
BRING IT UP EVERY SENTENCE.
WE KNOW HILLARY CLINTONED
33,000 EMAILS AND KNOW ABOUT
URANIUM ONE.
YOU ARE STILL GOING TO GO
BACK AND TALK ABOUT JARED
KUSHNER WHICH IS A WHOLE LOT
OF NOTHING BURGER.
>> WHY DO YOU GET TO DECIDE
THIS ISN'T.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
YOU PROBABLY WANT A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LOOK INTO
THE EMAIL PROBE.
>> WHY WOULD SOMEONE, AS
SEAN MENTIONED, WHY WOULD
SOMEONE DELETE 33,000 EMAILS
AND BLEACH BIT A SERVER, A
PRIVATE SERVER THEY HAD A
BASEMENT?
>> Sean: SUBPOENAED.
>> SHE SAYS THEY WERE HER
PRIVATE EMAILS.
I PROBABLY THERE IS MORE IN
THERE ABOUT YOGA.
>> Sean: YOGA, A FUNERAL AND
WEDDING.
33,000?
REALLY YOU BUY THAT?
>> I SEND A LOT OF EMAILS
PERSONALLY.
>> Sean: BILL DOESN'T HAVE
AN ACCOUNT.
>> BILL CLINTON DOESN'T
>> Sean: SHE SAYS BILL.
>> SHE MUST KNOW HER OWN
HUSBAND DOESN'T SEND EMAILS.
>> Sean: SHE WAS ASKED DID
YOU WIPE THE SERVER CLEAN
LIKE WITH A CLOTH?